momento de nuestra revista de prensa en
directo a América ya nos acompaña en el
estudio martamoya bienvenida Hola Rosa
Buenos días Marta hoy vamos a empezar en
la frontera ruso ucraniana no con un
tema de la mosqui Times que habla de
cómo los residentes rusos de esa zona se
sienten abandonados por las autoridades
de Moscú Por qué pues Rosa Este
reportaje del Moscú Times se centra en
la ciudad de sevénica que está en la
región de vélgorot y ha sido realizado
con residentes de esta ciudad que antes
tenía 40.000 habitantes y después de las
continuas incursiones militares del
último mes mes y medio quedan apenas
2.700 habitantes que viven en estos
momentos sin luz ni siquiera agua
corriente esta ciudad ha sido objeto de
bombardeos esporádicos desde el pasado
mes de septiembre cuando las tropas
ucranianas recuperaron la mayor parte de
la región de harquiz que es fronteriza
del lado ucraniano con región de
belgorot Sin embargo estas incursiones
militares que empezaron en el mes de
mayo y que sean intensificado a lo largo
de todo el mes y especialmente a
principios del mes de junio han dejado
130 ataques en la región de belcorot que
han dejado a su vez ocho muertos 60 y
nueve heridos y han dañado más de 1000
edificaciones en esta ciudad analistas
consultados por el Moscú Times dicen que
estas incursiones hacen parte de la
contraofensiva
ucraniana de verano para concentrar a la
a las tropas rusas en la frontera y así
bueno debilitar sus defensas en otros
puntos del frente de la guerra Allí se
ha creado además una unidad de
voluntarios que patrulla las calles y
protege a la ciudad de lo que dicen son
los saboteadores y los saqueadores
ucranianos sin embargo Ucrania nunca
reconocido estar detrás de estos ataques
dicen además que las autoridades rusas
no pueden ni garantizar la ley ni el
orden en esta región de belgorot Dimitri
uno de los protagonistas de este
reportaje dice además que es difícil
identificar al enemigo porque hablan el
mismo idioma las patrullas de
voluntarios han ayudado a las fuerzas
armadas rusas a evacuar a los civiles y
a dar ayuda humanitaria a aquellas
personas que se han quedado los que se
quedan reciben una compensación
económica del equivalente a unos 120
dólares pero dicen que no es suficiente
porque las autoridades los han
abandonado a su suerte y los que se van
parte de ellos se han refugiado en la
ciudad de belgorot que es la capital de
la región con el mismo nombre y otros
han huido a otros territorios de la
federación rusa sin embargo muy pocas
críticas al gremlin dicen que Ucrania y
Estados Unidos están detrás de estos
ataques bueno martes que precisamente no
el cuerpo de voluntarios rusos y la
legión libertad de Rusia los grupos que
reivindicaron algunas de estas
incursiones en belgorot han dicho que
kiev estaba al corriente no Aunque no
orquestró los ataques como tal y
precisamente Marta hablando de críticas
de pocas críticas así enfoca el artículo
que vamos a comentar ahora el Washington
post no que dice en Rusia no se puede
criticar a Putin Excepto si lo hace el
líder del grupo de mercenarios Wagner
concretamente Este título del Washington
post es criticar al ejército es un
crimen en Rusia pero no para el jefe
Mercenario prigó sin Jefferson y prigó
sin el líder de este grupo de Mercenario
otra vez en el centro de la polémica
sabemos que ha criticado abiertamente a
las tropas del kremlin incluso Bueno
pues esto para los ciudadanos rusos
normales y corrientes esto acarrearía
penas de prisión por un delito de
traición a la patria sin embargo pues
momento las consecuencias para el líder
preybochil son inexistentes y además
también han mostrado abiertamente Bueno
pues una ambición política que parece
osado en una nación que es bastante
digamos putincentrista también
ampliamente conocida su pugna con el
ministro de defensa sergeygu el último
capítulo de esta pugna pasaba la semana
pasada cuando decretó que todos los
cuerpos de mercenarios o voluntarios
tienen que firmar un contrato con el
Ministerio de defensa ruso antes de el
primero de julio un extremo al que el
grupo Wagner se ha negado el Washington
post dice además pregojin profesa total
lealtad a Putin pero también ha estado
dando discursos y realizando
conferencias de prensa en toda Rusia lo
que se parece mucho a una gira de
campaña una posible línea Roja en un
país donde cualquier desafío político se
considera una traición Entonces el
Washington se pregunta por qué Putin lo
tolera entonces analistas algunos
analistas dicen que Putin no podría
tener otra opción en estos momentos
porque a pesar de todo priorin es un
ferviente defensor de la guerra y dejar
de lado a un patriota sería una pérdida
para la credibilidad de Putin en la
defensa de lo que dice esta operación
militar especial otros analistas dicen
al Washington bosque Putin tiene una
confianza total en su rol personal y que
no percibe a prigon como una amenaza
depende Además del gobierno Ruso y en
cualquier momento cuando se pudiera ver
amenazado podría cortar todos los
suministros al líder del grupo Wagner
además que no tiene prigo sin cabida en
los medios estatales de comunicación
rusos sin embargo dicen estos analistas
que esto podría ser un error de cálculo
también dice este artículo del
Washington bosque cualquier represión al
líder del grupo Wagner podría alinear a
sus partidarios con los grupos de la
oposición rusas que bueno lidera Alexa y
navalni como sabemos y un dato que por
finalizar que dice el Washington post es
que según una agencia de investigación
independiente llamada Rush el 2% de los
rusos votaría en una carrera
presidencial que es el mismo porcentaje
que votaría a navalli eso sí muy lejos
del 30% de los rusos que volvería a
votar a Vladimir Putin bueno complicada
relación no de codependencia recordemos
además que el grupo Wagner ha ganado la
batalla más larga de esta guerra la de
backmuth para para Moscú precisamente y
Marta cerramos con una noticia que ha
desvelado Paul Mccartney xvitel en la
radio de la bbc Asia Rosa Paul McCartney
ha comentado Este martes en radio Ford
de la bbc que la Inteligencia artificial
vuelve a estar en el centro esta vez
para los fans de Los Beatles No será una
mala noticia porque ha dicho que van a
publicar la que será textualmente la
última canción del grupo por la
Inteligencia artificial no ha dado
detalles de qué canción sería Pero
algunas pistas sugieren que podría
tratarse de Nao andén todo ello porque
John Lennon
días antes de morir grabó unas canciones
en un radio cassette con su piano en su
apartamento de Nueva York y después yo
conocí viuda le traslado esta cinta a
Paul McCartney ahora por cuestiones de
la Inteligencia artificial Las pistas de
audio y de piano se han podido separar
las van a poder mezclar y esta canción
La última del grupo saldrá a finales de
este año bueno Marta pues estaremos
atentos a escucharla y a comentarla
muchísimas gracias por esta revista de
prensa Gracias Rosa